cette année c'est la paillette c'est
carrément ou le tout petit string ou le
maillot de bain une pièce qu'on peut
rouler même c'est beaucoup plus fait la
tendance cette année c'est beaucoup plus
le une pièce que le deux pièces la
deuxième constatation c'est que la plage
est comme la rue el assa mode bien
particulière il est difficile finalement
de s'y préparer à l'avance c'est une
ambiance que l'on va chercher à épouser
comment imaginer quand on est chez soi
pas mal fatigué encore un peu trop gros
que dans quelques temps on osera se
promener nu ou presque
en fait il semble que l'on y arrive très
facilement et puis on ne se déshabille
pas n'importe comment
chaque année on est nu et pourtant
différents ce maillot large comme une
ficelle mes chers comme un costume trois
pièces la société spectacle n'a pas de
prix la mode
fut-elle futile modèle quand même les
habitudes et parfois les corps car si
l'idéal féminin du début du siècle était
d'être plutôt gironde c'est bien la mode
qui l'a transformé